here's a clip of Jordan and I walking  the streets of Florence  Buon Giorno limoncello here's what I  like to do yeah when I'm walking around  I like to yell out random Italian things  I know Magna Lodi it just makes it look  like that's a pasta I think that it's  sometimes considered to be insulting  now when you yell at I don't think it's  considered a fake Italian word clearly  as an American not at all alone it  doesn't seem to bother anybody it  doesn't cause anyway see it's bothering  me you keep thinking it's offensive  people just think that I'm Italian I  vestal see I said pesto to him and he  said pesto back that doesn't mean he's  offended no sirree  we have a lot of funny adventures so be  sure to tune in for our Conan in Italy  special airing Wednesday  [Applause]  you